voilà le plan d'abord je vais monter sur
la scène pour tancer et distraire les
filles le temps qu'il faut pour que mc
fonce pour aller piquer l'herbe
kelly paula dans la bagnole prête à
démarrer vous êtes enceinte alors pas
question que je vous presse courir est
assez bas les tendances pour distraire
tout la sororité j'en suis pas certain
c'est déjà plus j'habite rien qu'en le
voyant encore je suis pas à temps je
suis un chien non j'ai pas lui pour bébé
non c'est le plus important l'huile pour
bébé ça fait ressortir les deux muscles
à cet endroit cellule un truc attend
attend ainsi pour tous bon allez go
haussé le ton au puits de taza g aucun
bouillant way road mois et demi en irak
a calé clinique